the timing of the german chancellor's
visit to kiev is significant ukraine
will celebrate its independence day on
monday
then on tuesday president petra
poroshenko is meeting russian president
vladimir putin for direct talks
the german government intends to show
it's on ukraine's side
the chancellor wants to send a very
strong signal
seeing that we support ukraine's policy
and that we're against the russian
strategy of destabilization and frozen
conflict
despite their differences merkel
apparently remains able to get through
to president putin
he seems to respect her as a tough but
trustworthy negotiator who believes in
compromise
germany has long held a key role in the
ukraine crisis
as a mediator and as policy coordinator
within the eu
the most important thing is for europe
to have a united policy eu unity was
important during the imposition of
economic sanctions and preventing any
split within europe remains extremely
important that's where germany's
leadership role comes in
merkel is backing poroshenko but she's
also pressing both him and putin to find
a political solution
germany wants to get diplomacy back in
gear there are high hopes for tuesday's
meeting between the russian and
ukrainian leaders